d
ou alors je suis professeur eps millions
et depuis plus de 20 ans si vous dire
que je n'ai pas le jeu n'est pas le
panache de vous parler de bateaux et de
deux grands voyages et pourtant le rôle
d'un prof cessé d'enseigner relativement
peu c'est beaucoup faire la recherche
allait l'entreprise travaillait sur
l'entreprise avec les entreprises pour
comprendre comment comment se développe
comment s organise que comment elle peut
le faire mieux ou moins bien et donc
transmettre ce savoir à des étudiants ou
et surtout en publiant en travaillant
avec les médias le grand public pour
transmettre ou savoir que l'on à son
entreprise et ma vie de chercheur a
changé ou a été métamorphosée il y à peu
près 15 ans quand j'ai rencontré un une
personne que je m'appelais françois qui
est venu me voir
envoyé par un ami parce que cette
personne avait un problème alors
françois c'était un cadre supérieur une
grande entreprise française 40 ans l'âge
des crises donc je m'attendais à quelque
chose autour de ça et donc ils viennent
me voir et me dit eh ben voilà j'ai un
problème je une brillante carrière
superbe j'ai réussi et là figurez vous
qu'on me propose de prendre la direction
d'une business unit dans un pays
étranger c'est un très gros pose c'est
une super promotion mon âge
super quel est le problème j'ai pas
envie d'y aller j'ai pas envie d'y aller
on ne vit elle est pas là ma vie c'est
avec ma famille c'est ici en france j'ai
trouvé qu'ils étaient en france j'ai
envie de m'engager dans ma ville
j'avais préparé un un début de carrière
politique c'est ça qui m'intéresse pas
et là je suis je suis coincé
et sam hanna frappé parce qu'en fait je
suis économiste de formation leur
économie en des grands agrégats des
grands de logix et abstraite soirée sur
l'entreprise de management à gouvernance
d'entreprise tous assez abstrait et
l'âge de rencontre la personne qui me
dit ton grands systèmes
au fond c'est rien par rapport à ma vie
et ma vie là c'est que j'ai pas envie
d'aller dessus et sa carrière là et ça
m'a conduit à repositionner mon propre
travail sur la question du travail
justement au fond le coeur de l'économie
le coeur l'entreprise c'est le travail
réel à travers des humains les gens il
buzze et mais ce sont des personnes
concrètes et c'est ça qui fait la
richesse c'est ça qui fait l'activité ça
paraît évident de le dire mais combien
de fois vous avez entendu parler du
travail dans les vignes travail réel des
gens font quoi quelle est leur activité
concrète c'est quoi la journée d'une
personne de travail qu'elles soient
cadres dirigeants ou aux ouvriers ces
quads c'est quoi le travail
et pourtant c'est le travail qui fait la
richesse sont la prends dans mes cours
d'économie
c'est le travail qui fait la richesse on
n'en parle pas il a disparu sur les
reporting des planifications les la
grande abstraction gestionnaire ap le
coeur même c'est des gens des hommes et
des femmes qu'ils matin se bougent se
lève pour aller travailler
le revenant à ce coeur là pourquoi le
travail c'est si important parce que des
gens qui travaillent sont c'est d'abord
un sujet qui travaillent vous allez
travailler vous avez du travail et vous
travaillez c'est d'abord une personne
qui travaille et qui est fier ont pas de
café voiture je visitais un chantier est
un truc qui m'a accompagné des riads et
10 les gens qui ont fait ça il doit être
fier ce magnifique salle et il a pas dit
ça va coûter bonbon ou c'est pourquoi
ils devaient être fier d'avoir fait ça
et oui il ya des sujets des gens dans la
première réaction conséquent cdg exister
j'ai fait ça travaille ses objectifs on
fabrique quelque chose on est performant
on s'est fixé un handicap
c'est le cas de dire en challenge un
défi une réalisation et puis on doit la
réaliser et on le fait c'est performant
ça marche travail objectif
et puis travailler toujours collectif on
travaille toujours avec d'autres
toujours en relation une chaîne de
valeur comme on dit est toujours un
avant et un après on est le client
travailler avec nous donc j'ai toujours
un briquet dans nos sociétés pour mon
travail
donc si le travail crée de la valeur
c'est pas parce qu'on est si le travail
humain est le travail de chaque personne
crée de la valeur c'est pas idéaliste
c'est le coeur même de l'économie
il se ne revient pas à ce coeur de
l'économie partir du travail quel qu'il
se fait pas des personnes concrètes on
racle économie on épuise les entreprises
c'est ce qui se passe avec la crise
c'est matt est donc j'ai géré orienté
mes recherches à partir des années là
cette question là mattel c'était de
montrer comment la crise est d'abord une
crise de l'essoufflement du travail
c'est un travail sans esprit son sens à
force d'accumuler de l'abstraction sans
esprit sensé finalement dans les
personnes qui nous pousse est thenergie
pour donner pour se lever le matin est
compris comme on l'a entendu un instant
nous fait cette histoire de bateaux des
personnes qui ne semblent pas avoir les
compétences et qui pourtant font un
effort apparemment démesuré pour gagner
parce que là elles sont leurs places dès
lors que le sujet qui travaillent ce
sens à sa place ce qu'il fait il envoie
le sens et il sait qu'il peut être
solide et ceux avec qui travaille le
travail pop 30 toute sa valeur tout son
sens mais aussi toute sa richesse
et c'est ça qui crée la valeur
économique oui je me suis réconcilié mon
économistes avec mes valeurs avec ma ma
relation à l'humain avec ce en quoi je
crois profondément la place de l'homme
la société je me suis réconcilié parce
que sans ça il n'y a pas d'économie et
depuis que je travaille cette question
en entreprise avec des grandes et
petites entreprises je suis frappé par
l'accueil de l'idée tu seras paix par le
fait que si vous rappeler à des
dirigeants à des managers au fond leur
travail à eux c'est d'épanouir le
travail des autres c'est de travailler
sur le travail c'est de faire en sorte
que ce travail soit le plus riche
possible bien vous il ya un écho qui
m'étonne toujours je crois que il est
d'autant plus important que les
organisations sont en train de changer
et vont changer parce qu'elle prenne à
bras le corps cette question du travail
humain travail au centre mais un travail
ils voyaient donner un travail
entrée sur la personne un travail centré
sur le collectif ça dépend pas
évidemment que des organisations il faut
pas attendre des organisations la
société des politiques ne sais quoi ce
changement de regard sur le travail
il fait ça dépend aussi de nous ça
dépend d'abord de nous je crois que
l'une des décisions les plus importantes
dans une vie c'est de choisir son
travail et vous savez et des moments de
bifurcation a bien sûr quand on est
jeune et qu'on sort d'une école mais
plus tard chaque moment de sa vie je
dédie à 40 ans et plus tard il n'y a
jamais de moment où c'est trop tard mais
être sûrs sur deux soit sûr de sa
vocation est ce que le travail que je
fais c'est le travail qui me permet
d'être pleinement humain est pleinement
la personne que je peux être ça c'est je
crois
l'une des grandes questions de notre vie
et de depuis précisément que je
travaille sur ces questions j'ai la
chance de rencontrer beaucoup de monde
tant que je le puis faut les aider à
discerner précisément sur la location
je raconte des histoires qui m'a frappé
récemment mais c'était un étudiant un
étudiant dit si j'aime voir je vais
l'appeler pierre pour viennent me voir
et me dit penser que vous intéresser aux
convocations
voilà mon problème je j'ai aujourd'hui
un choix je peux être en cause un boulot
de banquiers d'affaires aux états unis
et de traders à londres c'est
l'équivalent de trader à londres
ou alors je sais pas dans ma carrière
qu'ils ont pensé dit et financier donc
est ce qu'on pense et ce qui vaut mieux
que je commence par le trading des piges
haillan en bref débat cornélien dans son
coeur alors je lui pose la question que
je pose que je vous pose que je pose à
toute personne tuée une expérience du
travail dans ta vie qu'est ce qui t'a
fait grandir
quel l'expérience de travail est assez
de te dilatées quitte à te sentir mieux
qui t'a fait sentir toi même alors il
réfléchit un moment il me dit je suis
partie en coopération il ya quelques
mois ils étaient par tient un an mais
les gars car il s'était occupé dans un
bled il s'était occupé de pauvres et mti
voilà je me suis occupé ça et ce garçon
se met à pleurer dans mon bureau il se
met à pleurer certes il partait la
trader à londres et aux souvenirs de
cette expérience de travail il a été
tellement touché tellement ceux venus
dilatation de son goût de solesmes de
son coeur qui s'est mis à pleurer je
suis mais c'est moche
entre trading et d'angles affaire je
pense pas que ce soit le vrai choix tu
veux fuir quelque chose tonton vrai
choix c'est les relations humaines je
n'ai pas tout quitter nécessairement
pour t'occuper des pauvres peut-être ça
mais au moins des relations humaines
soient bien que c'est ça qui te fait dix
dates et voilà travail au coeur de
l'économie c'est une grande chance
d'être de notre de votre génération de
notre génération de pouvoir remettre le
travail aux kurdes l'économie mais
travailler au coeur de notre vie c'est
pas un détail
c'est vraiment un choix important la
vocation au travail pour le travail est
trop importante on laisse aux
organisations comme françois ou au
hasard comme pierre c'est vraiment la
faire de notre vie pensez-y
merci de votre attention